[Music]
this morning we're continuing our series
i
on earth our planet in peril in the lead
up to earth day this thursday
now a lot of people think soccer is
maybe the most beautiful game in the
world but a pro team in england
has the world on its mind advising other
teams from europe to the u.s
on their carbon neutral approach mark
phillips shows us
what may be the future of sports in a
climate changing
world
the rules of the game we call soccer but
which the brits who invented it
understandably call football haven't
changed much in 170 or so years
but at this minor league team in a small
town a couple of hours west of london
soccer sorry football is being
reinvented
forest green rovers are the world's
first vegan
carbon neutral professional sports team
and they got here
because they were so bad so it wasn't
winning and i wasn't making any money
the rovers were about to go under when
dale
vince the owner of a locally based
renewable energy company stepped in to
save them
did you have the big idea then that you
would take this
long established club that was in
financial difficulty and
not just rescue it but turn it into what
it's become this kind of ideal
now all of that kind of grew organically
like i say it was without any thought
other than saving the club
and then everything else became apparent
one thing at a time
the first thing that became apparent was
that vince a long time vegan
found himself not only in the sports
business but in the meat business
not for long you owned a team that that
fed its players meet
yes did it horrify you it horrified me
the club not only stopped serving meat
to the players they stopped serving it
to the fans
when there were fans before covid and a
funny thing happened
everybody liked the food former
carnivore players like dan sweeney say
it even improved their game
what are the benefits just faster
recovery times
before games pretty much you feel like
you've gotten way more energy really
yeah yeah yeah then another funny thing
happened
the team started winning they're now
fighting to move up into a higher
division of the english league system
being vegan is one thing but how do you
make forest green
really green not that hard
the club now powers its park with wind
turbines and solar panels
it plays on an organic field no chemical
fertilizers here
just seaweed even the water they use is
collected and used again
but still how do you go carbon neutral
you're in the sports business go to away
games your fans
travel all this stuff eats up eats up
energy
you've got to measure your carbon
footprint first then you've got to do
what you can to reduce it
and then what you've got left that you
can't reduce you offset by a scheme that
absorbs carbon
in some other way so the field is
organic
the players are vegans the power is
renewable
what's left the uniforms right now
they're bamboo but next years
are going to be made out of used coffee
grounds
seriously and the next step
a new stadium built not of carbon hungry
steel or concrete
but out of wood question to keep coming
back to is
why are you trying to create an example
here is it just part
of your own personal approach to life
that you want to run a business this way
do you know it's both that you happen to
have a football club
soccer we'd call it and that you could
turn it into and run it the way that you
wanted to run it
yeah i run everything the way i want to
run it
for cbs this morning i'm mark phillips
at forest green
rovers i'm still trying to figure out
how you make jerseys out of coffee
grounds
i have no answer to that but i wonder if
the vegan and carbon neutral organic
stuff
colors in any way the trash talk between
the players
but they're winning apparently they are
that's their victory